so like many of you I played a bunch of
watchdogs this week and while it's
undoubtedly a really fun game I was a
little bit disappointed about the game
world itself you know bugs and glitches
and weird physics things notwithstanding
the world of watchdogs the Chicago it
creates it doesn't really feel like a
real tangible place it feels like a
construct something made specifically
for the player there's nothing
necessarily wrong with that but it made
me ask the question what is it about
some game worlds that make them feel
real whereas others just feel like video
games
watchdogs is an open-world game in the
vein of many other Ubisoft franchises
the player is given a variety of
individual objectives in any given
sector of the city for instance access
this radio tower or hack this base each
sector has its very own set of these
missions and you're essentially given a
checklist of objectives to complete the
location style of these objectives are
handed to the player right at the start
of the game though early Assassin's
Creed games were more linear exploration
based experiences we've seen Ubisoft
play this card before most notably in
Black Flag where you were given a ship a
bunch of objectives and all the time in
the world to complete them destroying
bases hunting whales climbing vantage
points to unlock the map you name it
same with Far Cry 3 dozens of repeated
sectors with terrorists a climb basis to
destroy and animals to hunt these are
objectives that are either displayed
outright or unlockable throughout the
game this is not just an ubisoft
technique we've seen it in loads of
other open world games like in from the
second son Arkham City Just Cause 2 to
name just a few
it's become a staple of many open-world
games but at a cost the world of
watchdogs feels like it exists solely to
serve the player the objectives dotted
around the map the repeating missions
the upfront advancement of progression
now perhaps this is by design I mean
it's a game about understanding a city
as a system and then manipulating that
system to your own means but this makes
the game feel a lot less believable and
not all open world games unravel this
way take grand theft auto perhaps the
easiest game to compare watchdogs to but
also the poster child for believable
modern open worlds now maybe it's a bit
of an unfair comparison but bear with me
on this one the world of grand theft
auto is no stranger to a map full
objective points but the way in which
these are introduced to the player is
very different at the start of a GTA
game the map is almost empty and as you
make your way through the game you
unlock new areas new islands or in the
case of gta5 new objectives and side
quests around the map the more you play
the game the more objectives fill up the
map whether you've unlocked these via
the campaign or just stumbled across
them on your commute the map is filling
up alongside you
your characters uncovering mysteries in
the game world right as you the player
are becoming more familiar with the
world yourself it feels like natural
exploration and I know what you're
thinking it's easy to say the gtas
believable world because of the way the
people act realistically in the level of
detail in those games but really that's
not why they suck you in there are
plenty of nice touches and watchdogs and
infamous second son looks stunningly
beautiful and real at times but it's the
way these games invite us in the way we
uncover these worlds as we do real
places that makes them believable anyone
who's played early text-based D&D games
or role-playing games like Ultima or
even the Diablo series can understand
the difference between a world that
feels real as you explore it and one
that appears to have been laid out like
a play mat for the player you start
games like fallout and Skyrim with a map
that is hardly any objectives on it at
all you fill in that map yourself the
game is guiding you but the puppet
strings are hard to see it feels like a
real place that you were uncovering step
by step and empty areas of the map
entice you to explore them the world of
Red Dead Redemption feels like a vast
isolating environment
there were objectives to carry out all
over the place but they were just spread
apart so much that you were encouraged
to get lost in the empty space between
them and it's in that empty space that
you uncovered dozens of wonders of your
own these side quests enriched the game
with characters you may never have met
and the stories you might never heard
and the idea that you could have gone
through the entire game with Evan Kerr
enjoying any of them is a really
powerful one compare this to watchdogs
regardless of the scale of the game
world the marked objectives are so
densely packed together that you know
there's nothing in the space between
them we already know that there's
nothing important in these areas because
the game is outright telling us where
everything important is it destroys any
wonders this world could have had and
turns it into a construct or set of
levels like any other and the funny
thing is despite its living breathing
world watchdog's ends up being less
believable than many linear games the
mysteries of Midgar city 17 are even
Assassin's Creed games are unraveled
level by level but the world of
watchdogs is pretty much an open book
right from the off both in terms of the
environment and the activities therein
now there are other ways in which
watchdogs makes its world on immersive
the radio forces you to listen to CTOs
public service announcements all anyone
in the street ever talks about is being
hacked or robbed and people straight-up
recognize you in the street and take
photos so watchdogs is really trying to
make you feel like the center of the
world and that's exactly what the best
open-world games don't do words like Los
Santos Skyrim the capital wasteland the
deserts of Red Dead Redemption these are
worlds that are ambiguous to your
presence as if when you turn off your
console and went to bed the world inside
the game kept spinning sure by the end
of the game you've left your mark on the
world but these are places that don't
bend to your whim they feel like they
existed before you arrived and they'll
continue to do so long after you've
perished part of the wonder being in a
new place is exploring it the idea of
the unknown is a powerful thing what
exists behind the fog of war what will I
learn tomorrow that I didn't know today
it's part of why we wake up in the
morning and in video games it's why we
salivate at the idea of new game worlds
to explore uncovering a place as
mysteries makes us feel at home there it
creates a bond and our favorite
open-world games
understand this they invite us to
explore their world and to uncover the
world's secrets for ourselves games much
like real life or at the most powerful
when they surprise us there's no
surprise in watchdogs that doesn't make
it a bad game but what it does mean is
that memories of Ubisoft Chicago will be
long forgotten while those of man
chiliad Hennig instead and solitude will
live with us forever
robbed this lady's car
hit why you know just watch the video
game we probably go into that strip club
right everyone
that's popping off the idea that you
could have gone through the entire game
without ever encountering them it's a
really [__] loud truck right and the
idea that San Francisco has some of the
loudest cars in America that's quickly a
good-tasting she owes she was the bank
money got his ex-wife on the back way
looked at me that weird